البدايه من تطورات الهجوم غير المسبوق
الذي شهدته الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه
امس والذي اسفر بحسب الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
مقتل ثلاثه من جنوده واصابه ضابط برصاص
شرطي المصري نعم صحيفه معاريف الاسرائيليه
اوردت نقلا عن تحقيق اوليا للجيش
الاسرائيلي ان المجند المصري خطط للهجوم
بدقه وربما تلقى مساعده على مستوى التخطيط
في خبر نشرته اليوم ان المجند المصري مشى
مسافه خمسه كيلومترات من موقعه في الاراضي
المصريه في ظروف تضاريس صعبه للغايه حسب
وصفها واضفت ان المجند خطط لمسار التسلل
وعرف موقع الجنود الذي يبعد نحو 150 مترا
عن ممر الطوارئ في السياج
ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين قتلوا قنصا وفي
اشتباك مسلح وفقا لروايه الجيش الاسرائيلي
المكان هنا في الجانب الاسرائيلي عند معبر
العوجه للبضائع التجاريه عند الحدود بين
مصر واسرائيل في تفاصيل ما حدث فان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انه احبط فجر السبت محاوله
لتهريب كميات كبيره من المخدرات عند
الساعه السادسه صباحا سمع اطلاق نار في
محيط نقطه مراقبه تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي
غرب معبر العوجا بنحو ثلاثه كيلومترات في
التاسعه صباحا وجدت دوريه تابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي جنديا وجنديه اسرائيليين وقد
قتل
ظهر السبت اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي تجدد
اطلاق النار في محيط نقطه المراقبه وقال
انه اسفر عن قتل جندي اسرائيلي ثالث
واصابه ضابط اضافه لقتل مصري يرتدي بيتزا
الشرطه الجيش الاسرائيلي اوضح ان منفذ
الهجوم الشرطي المصري ووصفه بالمخرب وقال
انه لم يتسلل بل من معبر طوارئ مخصص لمرور
القوات الاسرائيليه الى الجانب المصري حين
الحاجه اما روايه الجيش المصري فمختلفه في
بعض التفاصيلها تحدثت عن عمليه مطارده
واطلاق نار بين احد عناصر الامن ومهربي
مخدرات اسفرت عن مقتل عنصر الامن وثلاثه
جنود اسرائيليين واصابه اثنين الجيشان
المصري والاسرائيلي قال كل على حذاء انهما
يجريان عمليات بحث وتمشيط في المنطقه كما
اغلقت الشرطه الاسرائيليه كل الطرق
والمحاور التي تؤدي الى الحدود مع مصر